hello welcome to video MH be amh be ok
the dutch defense yeah i'm pretty happy
with that line with white it's not that
it's brilliant but i somehow don't
handle the sorry the landing-grid dutch
variation so well so i'm okay with
playing on this type of position very
quick c5 yeah there's some way to t make
use of that and I know maybe a 95 idea
trying to play a play for quick
development yeah so he doesn't mind
doesn't mind to lose castling rights
maybe he can afford that I'm not quite
sure about it but maybe he can so
probably castling now on I don't think I
can immediately use this so let's castle
so yeah that's funny he wants to take
with a king yeah I guess no okay Virgil
lose time here and beat eggs really whoa
I thought night a4 would be pretty
awkward I is completely completely
unfazed it just just plays on and on and
on with this King there in the middle ok
don't quite get it I can take here then
a three black resign yeah what a
disaster yeah probably that is not play
volume this is at least now in this
precise way so here maybe a six or so I
don't know I mean he's got very little
in terms of development most of the time
like players play this castle and then
they go see 5 which him I don't know and
that looks looks tricky so maybe I don't
know maybe it is not that bad but he
really has to improve now a 6 looked I
mean jack I don't know ok I don't really
believe it and now I think he has to
play King takes even though it looks
crazy but I think he has to this looks
lost ready Knight b6 c5 hangs yeah yeah
I can also play d takes a c5
yeah this is also pretty awful yeah he
resides here early but it is a very bad
bad position like here I think I
probably take oxy once after having his
king is wide open and I don't even know
I mean I didn't didn't have to sacrifice
a pawn in for that for that good
position so fields are very okay very
okay for me okay thanks for watching